is your home in need of a refresh
whether it's your family your pets your
house gets you need to make some changes
in getting those houses clean right now
and you can do that with Zerorez and
joining us with more is co-owners Ben
and Doug McKee welcome back you guys I
love when you come because the magic of
Zerorez is put on display immediately
Doug if you want to show just what
Zerorez can do for your house and Ben
talk to us a little about the special
way you guys clean carpets so Doug's got
to show us we got this 300 horsepower
vacuum that's really loud but couple
that with our Zero Water technology and
you can see right away the clean that
Zerorez is able to provide and there's
no soaps there's no harsh chemicals and
it dries extremely fast now I am always
amazed like you go on that one time and
it picks up all of that and we're
talking about dirt and soil and I don't
know what else you guys have in your
garage but let's talk about something
that I know a lot of people have to deal
with and that's like pet
yeah we love our fur babies they tend to
make a mess in our homes but zero rest
we have an arsenal of products that can
actually address the stains and odors
left behind and we can even help remove
the hair left behind by our fur babies
oh nice so we we got you covered and we
could do this and we clean all sorts of
surfaces for you at your home or at your
business as well yeah businesses
looking to get the the workplace
Zerorez can help you and it's not just
carpets too you guys do a lot more we do
we clean air ducts we clean tile and
grout upholstery you name it we've got a
service for every surface countertops
I've had them counted by you guys before
you guys are absolutely incredible we
cannot believe the clean that you do
thank you so much for joining us uh
Zerorez sponsored this segment and you
definitely want to check out their
special of the month get your carpets
cleaned for as low as 35 dollars per
room plus get a hallway cleaned for free
you can call
702-840-333 or go online at
zerorezlasvegas.com for more minimums up
up high
we'll be right back